welcome to the share economy a place
where you can get a ride stay in a
stranger's home or get some Rando to put
together your IKEA furniture all at the
click of a mouse or a tap of your
smartphone a share economy is made up of
web-based companies who exchange goods
and services on demand usually linking
busy people up with those who want to
make some extra money it's an economy
built for and by Millennials they enter
the workforce during the recession they
can't afford cars and homes but they
can't afford some Wi-Fi and it boasts
the crunchy granola idea of empowering
regular people by creating an economy
that's efficient and eco-friendly one
way to do that is by folks making money
on things they're not using by offering
them up at a lower price and a regular
business take Airbnb you can find a
place for cheaper than a hotel and as a
provider let's some weird Italian
couples stay at your apartment over
Thanksgiving or you can make money on
that bike you never use and rent it to
someone who wants to get et home if it
sounds like the share economy is a
win-win for everyone
it's not that simple what if you don't
have a smartphone or internet access the
share economy is for the have sums not
to have nuts and though a flexible
schedule sounds like a perk steady pay
isn't a guarantee workers are at the
whim of companies who can decrease rates
and increase their cut whenever they
please kind of like a pimp workers also
don't qualify for health insurance paid
sick leave vacation or any normal
employee benefits that some companies
never wanted to pay for in the first
place then depending on the company
their extra costs like gas employment
taxes and car and home maintenance
things that end up falling to workers
and with all the extra cars on the road
riders and money are being drained from
public transportation what are you
looking at from a business perspective
the growing share economy has major
impacts on traditional businesses the
hotel and cab industries are being
squeezed by cheaper and more convenient
alternatives you might be saying well
hotels and cabs just need to catch up
with the times
what traditional industries are for
better or worse regulated while until
recently Airbnb and lyft were not
depending on where you live and hotels
have regular safety inspections so that
you don't say
in a fire and there are zoning
restrictions not everyone wants to live
next to a hotel or come home to find a
xxx freak fest cuz that happened plus
what's to prevent a landlord from
evicting you and air being being the
entire buildings not much cuz many are
so can you really call this sharing or
is it just business as usual and more
aggressive than usual relying on
outsourcing messed up labor practices
and exploitation critics would say yes
but there are some companies trying to
stay true to the real share economy like
loco Nam --ax a worker own version of
TaskRabbit all workers have equal voting
rights in the company or the numerous
taxi co-ops now using apps the hacker
and maker spaces or bike kitchens in
your local gentrifying neighborhood so
is this just peer-to-peer capitalism or
peace love and sharing what do you think